[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben wir müssen über chemnitz
scherze machen weil wir abbilden was
passiert in der woche vor unserer
sendung und an dem thema werden wir
nicht vorbeikommen aber klar gibt es da
aspekt daran die ich als privatperson
auch eher bedrückend finde als lustig
aber der fluch der heute show ist im
laufe der nächsten tage muss uns
irgendein ansatz dazu einfallen denn
alle anderen ich schon durchgenudelt
haben
[Musik]
bei einigen dieser leute betrachte ich
das natürlich als auszeichnung ich habe
zwar schon vor jahren aufgehört alles zu
lesen was auf unserer facebook-seite hat
auf der der heute show und so als
antwort auf eine sendung gespiegelt wird
aber ich weiß natürlich dass wir uns da
viele viele feinde erarbeitet haben und
bei den meisten die ich da im fernsehen
hat kann ich damit auch gut leben wenn
sich durch uns bestimmte leute plötzlich
für themen interessieren diese vorher
nicht auf dem radar habe ich das schön
weil ich das beklage dass deutschland im
moment auf ein thema reduziert ist wenn
wir manchmal schaffen den fokus auch auf
andere themen zu lenken ist schon viel
gewonnen aber ich habe mich schon vor
jahren von der illusion verabschiedet
das satire tatsächlich etwas verändern
kann in einem land da wir über bestimmte
themen immer noch reden wie vor zehn
jahren als sie heute schon angefangen
hat wenn man sieht was sich alles gar
nicht verbessert hat seitdem dann wäre
es echt vermessen zu glauben man könnte
mit dem was wir da machen irgendwas
bewegen
[Musik]